you and ross uh ross is somebody who
i feel like has also kind of laid the
blueprint on how to be a successful
entrepreneur one of the easiest best
partners i've ever worked with i mean
he's one of the hardest working smartest
easiest partners i've ever had straight
up yeah because you've obviously
collaborated with a lot of artists on
the on that side of the game right and
i'm sure sometimes it's a little bit you
know things haven't worked out sometimes
and i'm sure you know some people are
just scared to use their platform to
promote the [ __ ] you're working on like
rose he's getting on instagram he's
pushing that [ __ ] he's not playing he's
a businessman and also he understands
the long-term play you know my advice to
a lot of people out there a lot of
people are looking for that money right
now they want their money right now what
can i get right now there's power in
building equity you know what i mean
like when i look at my equity and
cookies alone like the weedside we
talked about the clothing side we look
at the weed side we're getting we're
going to get there for sure yeah so i
know what my equity is i'm not i only
take a small salary from cookies we saw
i get like a salary that's almost
laughable when
the type of [ __ ] i do but
the equity is there if i ever want to
pull so he understands that long-term
play and that's why me and rose work so
good together because he knows we're
building something that's super
long-term especially when we open up
cookies florida his brand's going to
dominate out there because he's been
such an easy guy to work with and we
take that in the back of ryan we're like
cool when we open up florida
we're going to have 400 000 square feet
of indoor cultivation i'm a petition
heavy rotation we're probably going to
make a store dedicated to his brand
colin zav fully decked out with his
logos everywhere like i just appreciate
the hard work and the vision and
long-term play because there is a big
exit